we our players have already shown
clearly that designs which fold in
principle don't fold in practice so
they've been very good at folding
incorrect RNAs and excitingly enough
some of our players have designed RNAs
which actually do fold correctly in
practice that is to say in the lab and
so now the community is sort of abuzz
about why those folded properly and
trying to generate hypotheses that
explain that and then synthesize more
RNAs which actually do fold properly so
they've really it's a game but they've
taken to this just like a scientific
community and in fact online when they
communicate with one another they're
generating knowledge they're discussing
hypotheses and they've built in some
sense their own scientific community
around this game and we hope to emerge
these ideas ultimately with the full
scientific community by submitting
papers based on what the community is
doing so the scientific community at
large is first of all invited to play
although our some of our players are
pretty good and also we're discussing
ways in which we can take problems chart
of interest to other research groups and
apply them in the game so that in some
sense a scientist can come to us and say
I would love to have 10,000 people look
at my problem can you make that happen
and so I mean that's one of the really
exciting completely new possibilities
that we're exploring that the Internet's
making possible which is how can we
apply a hundred thousand people to one
scientific problem instantly